all right this video is about the
incident in Chicago what we now suspect
is a hate crime but we have every reason
to believe is a hate crime that took
place involving a kidnapping of a
developmentally delayed white person by
four black alleged perpetrators now but
but to even get into the beginning of
this let's just debunk the two talking
points that my subreddit my youtube
channel my email my Twitter feed it's
all been filled with for the last few
hours which is number one David won't
cover this incident and then there's a
dot dot dot either because the alleged
perpetrators are black or because the
victim is white or fill in the blanks
David won't cover it well obviously
that's wrong I'm covering it right now
and number two David will deny that it's
a hate crime because although David is
supportive of hate line hate crimes
legislation he would never say that when
the perpetrators are black and or the
victim is white that you could say that
that's a hate crime and as you will
quickly see that that is could not be
more wrong as well so let's first
discuss the facts of the story then we
will discuss the hate crime angle and I
think I have to discuss the alleged
black lives matter angle although I've
not been able to find that it's actually
a legitimate angle but because it is
something that's circulating and has
been parodied by some conspiracy
websites I will talk about it so what do
we know about the facts we know that
four black people have been charged with
a hate crime there was a video broadcast
live on Facebook which showed a mentally
disabled white man being beaten up
threatened with a knife being forced to
drink from a toilet absolutely horrific
went on for hours police eventually
found the victim walking on the street
seemingly disheveled confused distraught
and during the video you hear the
suspects trash talking both white people
and specifically Donald Trump now the
video that's been posted by
numerous Chicago media outlets shows the
victim with his mouth taped shut and
sort of slumped over in the corner of a
room at another point the video shows a
wound on the top of the man's head one
person is seen pushing the man's head
with their foot and you also see at one
point sort of a red band around the
victims hands he reportedly was tied up
for 4 to 5 hours an absolutely horrible
depraved crime this sort of shifted from
being one type of hate crime initially
to I I mean I guess we would say two
types of hate crimes in a sense
initially the reports were that this man
was singled out as a victim because of
his developmental delay alone and that
race was not a factor since then though
authorities have said you know we are
now considering this a race-based hate
crime as well because of the use of not
only the sort of anti disability
language that's in the video but also
the anti white racial slurs that the
black suspects used in the video and of
course not only individuals with
disabilities are a protected class under
hate crimes legislation race of course a
protected class under hate crimes laws
now the victim was a classmate of one of
the attackers and the the understanding
that I have now is that the victim
initially went would that person
voluntarily and of course this got very
very ugly so we have a hate crime here
if anybody is looking for me to say in
any kind of even vague words that this
maybe is not a hate crime or not a
serious of a hate crime because the
perpetrators in this case are black and
the victim is white but that I don't
know why you would think that would be
my perspective although I have made it
very clear over the last many years on
the David Pakman show that I support
hate crimes legislation
I've never even alluded to the idea that
white people can't be the victims of
hate crimes or black people can't be the
perpetrators of hate crimes and if
anybody can point to
on the YouTube channel or anywhere that
I've said that would suggest that by all
means please send it to me okay let's
now just delve a little bit into the
hate crime angle and then I'm gonna go
into the black lives matter piece of
this some who are against the concept of
hate crimes legislation and protected
classes are against it on the basis that
they believe if you have hate crime laws
you are saying to some victims that the
crime they were victims of is not as
serious because there was not a
protected class motivation there whether
it's race or gender national origin or
disability or whatever the case may be I
completely reject that and hate crimes
legislation is something I've been
studying for a long time what hate
crimes legislation is saying is not that
if you happen to be a member of a
protected class that the crime is more
serious it's actually sort of different
if the perpetrators selected their
victim at least in part because of their
membership in a protected class based on
their race whether it's white black
whatever the case may be based on their
gender based on their sexual orientation
increasingly a protected class in hate
crimes legislation then that needs to be
punished above and beyond just the crime
perpetrated against the individual
because it is intimidate or II and in a
sense an attack on all members of that
class and as a society we want to make
it very clear that not only is this a
crime at the individual level but these
broader selections of victims based on
their membership in classes based on
characteristics that we want to protect
people from being victims over in
society is going to be punished even
more seriously okay so that's the hate
crimes angle absolutely everything that
has been said so far leads me to believe
that this was absolutely a hate crime
motivated not only by the disability of
the victim but also by the victims white
race
full stop let's talk about the other
aspect
some have alleged that there's a
connection here between the alleged
black perpetrators and the black life
matter movement so far police have said
there's no indication whatsoever of that
connection media have started going to
black lives matter for sort of reactions
or responses I think that there's no
need to do that additionally when you
have an amorphous group like black lives
matter the idea that there would even be
someone at black lives matter as an
organization that would speak for or to
the allegation that individuals were or
not quote associated with black lives
matter none of it really makes a lot of
sense to me and I don't think that that
angle makes sense to to approach in
terms of let's interview all sorts of
black lives matter people to get them on
the record about this incident however
in under 24 hours there's this hashtag
that's been created
BLM kidnapping it was mentioned nearly
500,000 times on Twitter it became one
of the top five Twitter trends across
the country and some of the sort of
normal characters are involved in this
Paul Joseph Watson who's involved with
the conspiracy site a site website
Infowars was among the first to tie the
attack to black lives matter you I don't
I won't do a whole thing here about
Infowars but Infowars and Alex Jones
many people in my audience are already
familiar with them Glenn Beck has also
sort of jumped on the bandwagon blaming
black lives matter he tweeted quote
stand up with me and demand justice in
Chicago for the beating of a disabled
Trump supporter by black lives matter
not only is the connection to black
lives matter without evidence at this
point the I've not seen anything that
says that the victim was a trump
supporter either so if something and
I'll go I'll preempt also what will
certainly be the comments in reaction to
this video which is if something
definitively ties this incident to black
lives matter I have no problem reporting
it and I will report it and for
everybody who's tweeting me and posting
on Facebook etc the idea that I will
hide this story or whitewash the story
or minimize the story or not
I hate crime there is absolutely no
basis in fact on which that allegation
can be made that I am aware of and if
you believe that there is by all means
get in touch and let me know where
you're getting that idea